[Musique]
ensuite huitième journée de mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites le
service de train et RER a été perturbé
selon Axel personne secrétaire général
CGT cheminots de Trappes il fallait
compter la moitié des trains supprimés
sur la ligne N et 1/3 des trains
supprimés sur la ligne C du côté de
l'éducation à l'échelle de l'académie de
Versailles 5% des enseignants du collège
se sont déclarés en grève ils étaient
14% dans les lycées et du côté des
universités des étudiants opposés à la
réforme des retraites ont bloqué
l’université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines à Versailles les rendez-vous
de l'emploi organisent un job dating
destiné au Seigneur de plus de 45 ans
l'événement aura lieu jeudi de 14h à 16h
à l'hôtel de ville de Versailles le but
mettre en avant les profils expérimentés
auprès d'entreprises privées publiques
d'associations ou encore de cabinets de
management vendredi 17 mars un autre
rendez-vous se tiendra au Centre
Commercial ouest-fille Vélizy 2 à
vélizy-villacoubl ay cette fois-ci
l'événement est destiné à tout public
dans la vente et la restauration 75
offre sont à pourvoir mardi 14 mars à
Noisy-le-Roi des interpellations ont été
conduites par la gendarmerie nationale
des individus ont été auditionnés ils
sont suspectés d'avoir cambriolé le
domicile du joueur du PSG presnel
kimpembe le 25 novembre 2022 le
préjudice total est estimé à environ
5000 euros
[Musique]